hey 42 here most people in the 18th
century only had a proper wash twice a
year welcome to RIF Finding Nemo a movie
about the suffering of a captured
clownfish ironically caused home
aquarium demand for them to triple the
first baseball gloves were flesh color
inkay spectators noticed and accused
players of cowardice only a fifth of the
Sahara Desert is Sun the rest consists
of mainly gravel in 2007 a woman
collapsed and lay on the ER floor of
Martin Luther King jr. harbor hospital
in Los Angeles for 45 minutes as
hospital staff ignored her
a janitor mopped the floor around her as
she vomited blood
she was then arrested by police for
causing a disturbance and died on the
stretcher takeout restaurants existed in
ancient Rome with service counters
opening onto the streets to pick up food
more than 200 existed in Pompeii and
most of its homes lacked dining or
kitchen areas suggesting that cooking at
home was unusual to improve their
ability to swallow hotdogs the
International Federation of competitive
eating is studying black holes as a boy
Roald Dahl taste tested new chocolate
bars for Cadbury's 80% of all food has
sugar added to it it will cost the US
government less money to provide homes
to the homeless than it does to leave
them on the street it is as difficult
for a bacterium to swim through water as
it is for a human to swim through syrup
the first atomic bomb dropped on Japan
was assembled whilst the aircraft was
actually in flight this was done to
avoid detonation whilst taking off
because bombers kept crashing and
burning on the runway it took them 25
minutes to assemble a weapon whilst in
flight as a nuclear safety inspector
Homer Simpson earns about $20,000 more
than
the average American in the 19th century
circumcision was used to treat epilepsy
hernias lunacy and paralysis the last
film
rented out by blockbuster was 2 2013
comedy this is the end thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42